welcome back to the david pakman show my
name is jesse dollamore and i would ask
that uh if you've been enjoying me uh
guests hosting for david over the past
last couple days the uh check me out i'm
at dollamore that's on youtube and
twitter
and uh the rest of them anyway thanks a
lot
so
mike lindell the the my pillow guy his
symposium has been going on the last
couple days and it has been
a mess
from the very start starting with the
delay because they were hacked
because you know he's got so much
incredible
uh critical information for the american
public that people need to hack to get
him off off the rails
well today was no different
in fact i got a couple clips here to
share that really just they give you a
flavor for the nonsense and for the
the the chaos
that anything involving mike pillow
brings
here's the first clip of an absolute
expected moment
where they're blaming technical problems
of course on conspiracy it's quite
coincidental that the video feed breaks
and the live streaming platforms break
as soon as we start talking about this
that my friends is a man named ron
watkins
ron watkins who is thought by many to be
q
who ran 8chan or one of those other
conspiratorial hate websites
and uh he is is all but admitted on an
hbo's uh documentary that he's cute
that's the kind of uh
character and caliber of individual that
mike pillow
mike lindell has at this cyber symposium
to uncover the truth of donald trump's
win in the 2020 election
that's not all though
get this speaker
it really is just emblematic it sums
everything up in the trump era exactly
how far down the rabbit hole people have
gone with their disrespect for expertise
their disregard
for
truth and journalism and
everything that we should hold true in a
free society watch this ladies and
gentlemen i'm not a computer guy i don't
know
what most of this stuff means but i've
been researching this election since
november 3rd
and i can tell you right now that
everything we're seeing right here we
saw in antrim county the adjudication
logs being deleted
it was absolutely censored by the media
most people don't know that this isn't
anything new
we've seen it in antrim county we've now
seen it in maricopa county and we're now
looking at it with our very own eyes in
colorado
what is colorado matter why are they
attacking colorado we need to wake up as
people and you the cameras in the back
there not all of you but the cnns of the
world you guys need to start reporting
this and stop fact checking it
and the crowd
goes wild the small
yet present crowd
did you catch some of those things that
should frighten you it should amuse you
but it also is there's an element of
cringe there that goes beyond just
that guy's a dumb ass
uh for one
he admits i'm not a computer guy
i don't understand a lot of this stuff
but
i'm going to offer my unfettered opinion
as though it's qualified and then spouts
a series of debunked conspiracy theories
that have been led by
the charge of have been led by
mike lindell and donald trump and lynn
wood and
the rest of these purveyors of
conspiracy and
propaganda then that last comment
should give you pause
start reporting
and stop fact checking
stop reporting but or start reporting
but please
please
stop with your infernal fact checking
it's getting in the way of our
propaganda
unbelievable
these are the times we live in right now
if you thought it couldn't get any worse
while donald trump with president it has
absolutely the the the train has jumped
the track
the trump train
has has veered it's careened into a wall
and now it is just in shambles
it is a pile of twisted metal and
carnage
and this is what we got
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable
climate-controlled sleep solutions to
sleep better their flagship products are
the uhler sleep system and the cube
sleep system which is what i have both
are hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too they'll give you 20 off
everything when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video